This video is sponsored by Blue Apron,
the first hundred wisecrack fans to sign
up for blue apron at the link in the
description will get $50 off the first
two weeks.
Stick around for some Tacos.
Hey,
why is it cracked?
Jared again,
for a franchise so surrounded than
mystery,
it seems fitting that nobody had a clue.
The cloverfield paradox had even been
made,
let alone that it was being released
within hours of its announcement during
the super bowl.
Now there are plenty of reasons why the
cloverfield paradox should have worked
and plenty of reasons why it didn't,
but we're going to focus on the element
that makes to largely unrelated scripts
so unique and cohesive and makes the
third one such an epic fail that
element,
our relationship to reality and trauma.
Welcome this wise crack addition on the
cloverfield paradox,
what went wrong and spoilers ahead for
all of the cloverfield movies before we
dip into that secret sauce,
a recap of the cloverfield paradoxes in
order.
The year is 20 slash 28 and the world is
in the midst of an energy crisis.
Be Crew aboard cloverfield station are
orbiting Earth to test the experimental
shepherd particle accelerator,
which they hope will save the world by
producing safe,
clean energy just before they turn on
the machine.
Though we overhear an interview with a
writer who thinks that turning on the
particle accelerator will open a
wormhole to other dimensions and
release.
God knows what,
onto an unsuspecting population
the likes of which we have never seen
and surprise.
This is exactly what happens there,
teleported into another dimension across
space where they experienced the
combined horrors of Phantom limbs,
creepy crawlers,
and faulty wiring.
The crew must figure out how to get home
and well,
you can probably figure out where it
goes from there.
If there's one thing we should be
excited about getting into the
cloverfield paradox,
it's answers.
What was the giant monster that attack
New York at the end of the first one?
Did it survive the nuke?
If we hope to get those answers in 10
cloverfield lane,
well we're out of luck.
Instead we get Walter Sobchak reminding
us that this isn't nom.
There are rules.
Yeah,
that's great.
Sorry,
I just got a little excited.
Well,
keeping that point
and as our protagonist escapes his
clutches,
she enters a world of pain and aliens
come on,
but the cloverfield paradox does give us
answers those giant monsters.
It's from another dimension,
the camcorder video.
It might not even be from the same
timeline,
so why isn't getting these answers more
rewarding.
Cloverfield and 10 cloverfield lane are
both films about trauma,
both the trauma one might associate with
war or natural disaster or extra
dimensional aliens destroying your home
and the trauma of being physically
trapped in a relationship with a person
that's going to go full Jack Torrance at
any minute,
ears johnny 10 cloverfield lane brings
up all the same aspects of abusive
relationships.
Possible gas lighting.
There is nowhere to go,
Michelle and threats of violence
interspersed with normal family fund,
but the first two movies aren't just
about dealing with trauma.
They are about the impossibility of
fully comprehending that trauma.
These insanely violent encounters with a
lack of closure.
Speak to one of the fundamental
difficulties of navigating the world for
philosopher and sometimes Klepto Maniac
Jacques Lacan.
There exists a fundamental human
inability to fully grasp what he calls
the real or the world as it truly is,
who were field throws us in the midst of
an alien invasion that evades easy
description.
We're often given the byproduct of
what's happening or people's reactions,
but almost never get the source of the
turmoil and unexplainable way like when
the head of the Statue of Liberty comes
rolling down the street or a
horrifically disfigured woman is begging
for help.
First cloverfield the reality of what's
happening only sparsely comes in new
segments in the background.
One of the ways cloverfield achieves
this is with perspective.
It's filmed pov style shot by the
characters in the movie and begins with
a detailed look at our main cast of
characters during a party for the
protagonist rob in the middle of the
Shin Dig.
They're interrupted by an explosion
signaling the monster invasion,
their battle for survival.
Cinder cut with older video that is
being recorded over,
which gives you glimpses into the
relationship between rob and Beth.
This subjective point of view means we
only ever get hints of where and what
the monster is.
How the military are responding to it
and even what it looks like,
you know,
just like you would in real life by
shooting it this way.
We don't know what kind of monster they
are facing,
but we do know who the characters are
and what they're facing personally.
10 cloverfield lane employs a similar
technique.
It doesn't use the same Pov south who
cut us off from the reality of what's
happening,
but rather uses a concrete bunker to
similar ends.
The protagonist Michelle wakes up in a
bunker that she can't leave for reasons
that seemed suspicious to say the least
she's told she was rescued.
Give it us how I saved your life.
I think that's acceptable
and that the outside world is deadly
outside of here.
Now,
if we suspect that Howard is preparing
to where Michelle skin,
we get just enough interaction from the
outside world to give credence to his
story,
but not enough to truly know what's
happening.
As the movie ends,
we get enough information to let us know
that things aren't going great for
earth,
but not much else.
The control of information in both
movies is what makes them so tense and
entertaining.
We have to fill in the gap which instead
of being frustrating makes with the sort
of thing that spawns endless.
Fan theories for Lacan that reality,
which seems to evade us the real,
is disconnected from our own personal
experience only through language or what
he calls the symbolic can we bridge the
gap between our minds and the reality
beyond them.
What cloverfield explorers is the chasm
between the real and language,
the inability to bridge that gap,
the characters and us.
The audience want answers.
We want to understand what is happening,
but the film withholds the language to
explain it.
That chasm for Lacan is called Lac and
it's what drives the tension of the
first two movies.
We all know what it's like to be at a
loss for words during a terrible event.
Footage of nine slash 11 shows onlookers
covering their mouths in silent horror
while watching the tragic events happen
in front of them.
It's no secret that these cinema verite
found footage style of the original
cloverfield was inspired by the events
and coverage of nine slash 11,
that kind of cultural trauma runs deep
and was still a raw nerve at the time of
the trailers release.
Mass entertainment wasn't willing to
return to these sorts of disaster movies
right away,
but the movie is able to tap into that
post nine slash 11 anxiety by borrowing
from the structure of hygiene movies
there by using a symbol to represent
that shared trauma.
This is what makes it so cathartic.
10 cloverfield lane released some eight
years later at a time of cultural
uncertainty and change was a paranoid
thriller that makes you question the
people around you against this gap
between language and reality.
The cloverfield paradox gives us its
antithesis sites.
This is the paradox.
Excuse me,
particles interacting with each other
across two dimensions.
Okay,
I'm going to sit down to have distinct
realities in a multiverse.
While there are certainly unexplained
events like why the hell did Mondays arm
keep moving after it was detached?
The whole premise of the movie trans
dimensional travel explains the origin
of the cloverfield event in the first 15
minutes of the movie
monsters,
Demons East to clarify,
you believe their efforts to solve the
energy crisis might unleash demons and
not just hearing that in the past,
in the future,
in other dimensions,
sure.
We're not saying mysteries can't be
solved or that science can do it,
but it shouldn't be as background noise
in the first half of the movie turns out
the terrifying,
ineffable monstrosities that have
invaded earth for reasons beyond our
imagining happened because sites little
disappointing isn't it,
and if you're going to give an
explanation or revelation,
there's a certain way to do it.
Good examples tend to give us a paradigm
shift or clarify motives.
In exceptional cases,
they can give you an entirely new way to
view the events prior,
like when you find out the truth about
Tyler durden or the men in black.
How does quantum entanglement add to or
reframe the original cloverfield
stories?
It doesn't,
and besides breaking away from the kind
of trauma that defined the first two
movies,
there is no central fear or shared
trauma for the audience to latch onto.
If cloverfield was the fear of an
invasion and 10 cloverfield lane was the
fear of other people,
what's the central fear of this movie?
Fear of particle accelerators,
peak oil by explaining way,
the mystery almost as an afterthought.
You Rub the audience not just of their
mystery but there catharsis.
While yes,
explaining a mystery ruins the fun is
kind of an obvious point.
It's what creates our desires for
mystery that is important to the
cloverfield movies.
MILIKAN's idea of lack gets to the heart
of understanding why we love a good
mystery and why jj Abrams property
seemed to have such a hard time with
resolving those mysteries.
We're looking at you last just to the
reality around us always evades easy
answers and the to describe it.
We don't want everything explained,
not just because we all like a good
conspiracy theory,
but because of the catharsis that comes
with these shared experience of
realizing that some things can't end
sometimes shouldn't be put into words.
The first to cloverfield movies knew
this and played on that,
which is what made them so interesting
and ultimately rewarding.
The cloverfield paradox paradoxically
ruins the fun by giving us all the
answers and pretty half baked ones at
that.
So what do you think wisecrack can the
movie have more tastefully explain the
mystery.
Let us know what you think in the
comments,
and as always,
thanks for watching.
Hayes
cloverfield may not have been the PSI
Phi mind bender we'd hoped for,
but as I've found,
everything is made better with Tacos and
in this case,
spicy black bean and caramelized onion
tacos from blue apron,
Blue Apron unleashes your inner Gordon
Ramsay by sending farm fresh ingredients
along with an easy to follow recipe
right to your door.
You never have to leave the house again.
Finally,
in fact,
the first hundred wise crack fans to
sign up with blue apron via the link
below.
We'll get 50 bucks off your first two
weeks.
Each meal takes 40 minutes or less to
cook,
all under 800 calories per person and
with a large selection of menus updated
weekly,
there's something for the carnivores,
Vegetarians and really picky teens and
the family.
You know what I'm talking about?
Teens,
if you're looking for something extra
flavor fold,
then I'd recommend there Mediterranean
menu featuring dishes like Oregano,
chicken and calibrate and Chili shrimp h
perfect for all the lovers of olive oil
and Spain.
Click below again to get this awesome
deal and I'm off to eat a family sized
portion by myself.
Peace guys.
Yeah.